how are you both doing today you're
welcome thank you how are you
i'm doing excellent i am very excited to
talk to the two of you i thought this
movie was fantastic i'm sure you're
hearing that from everyone coming in the
room today so let me just say i'll echo
the choir it's fantastic um
i know both of you are offered a lot of
projects and i am curious for both of
you what was it about this script and
this material that says i have to do
this um
i i actually had just seen the show the
summer before they announced they were
going to be bringing it to
film and
i immediately called someone and said if
they ever make
a movie of this i have to be a part of
this i don't care
i'll i'll do a walk on roll i thought
the story was so moving and so important
and something i thought that uh
would be a rich opportunity to be a part
of um so i was
thrilled when i got a phone call to be
involved in this
yeah i pursued it so to speak
shamelessly
yes
i think i'm with amy this was like i saw
the show shortly after it opened and was
so moved by it so blown away by ben and
everything that he did and everybody in
it and and of course we listened to the
soundtrack endlessly i knew the songs
you know inside and out were they were
always playing in our in our car and um
and and when this opportunity came up i
couldn't i actually couldn't quite
believe it i was like whoa you know it
just seemed it was so so special and i
think also given the time that we were
in the fact that we made this during
covid and it was such an important
message and so much about connectivity
and seeing one another and being part of
something that made it even i think even
more important
to do
i really was blown away by ben's
performance in this obviously he's done
it on the stage but watching him
um sing through tears and be able to
deliver
that those songs so emotionally like it
wrecked me um just wrecked so i'm
curious for both of you can and i never
asked this question but can you talk
about working with ben and seeing this
amazing performance up close
he he is i mean i when i first saw him
on on broadway like i said it was just
we were just like a couple of minutes
into the show and i turned to my
daughter and i said i've never seen
anything like this you know he's
he has such an extraordinary ability i
think i think you know vocally that's
sort of one thing but his his the way
he's able to kind of manifest emotion
through that that's that's something
that was so
he's so immediate he's so alive and and
so and and that part is hard man it's
dark this is a kid who's really
suffering you know so
so he was
i i just he's he's very very special as
a talent yeah he really is
yeah i it's it's was completely
immersive um for me to be a part of um
to part of the scenes where uh he was
singing
um
it's hard for me to talk about because i
almost start crying every time i talk
about it my husband endlessly teases me
how i can't talk about making dear evan
hansen without crying
because it's so like it's so got into my
cells it's like a part of me now and i
um
because because of what everyone brought
to it and and ben
specifically um
he sings uh words fail and the amount of
motion that he has to generate
and he's doing that not only in like a
two-hour show but he's doing that all
day long
um day after day while we're filming and
uh
it was it was special and it was unique
and it's something i will uh carry with
me
i already gotta go i'm gonna say again
congratulations on being part of such a
special film and thank you so much for
your time
thank you thank you